just when you thought tax reform
couldn't get any better the worst people
on earth voted today to save taxpayers
billions of more dollars despite
warnings from nikki Haley and President
Trump the United Nations voted 128 to 9
to condemn the United States for moving
its embassy in Israel to the capital of
Israel the United States has two words
for those countries and they're not
Merry Christmas
so those countries might not lose
foreign aid we will explain why
President Trump should go further and
defund the UN fala Lala lalalala
then the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
what a glorious news cycle this is the
last show before Christmas before New
Year's we're gonna not gonna be on the
air next week and we're gonna do a nice
little Christmas show but Nikki hailey
gave us an extra present how sweet
before we get to any of that I've got to
tell you about thrive market this was
another Christmas present that came in
early we have another sponsor and these
guys are great I told you
Shapiro's hasn't paid me since he gave
me that election bet check so I really
count on freebies from sponsors this one
is really really good this is thrive
market it is the greatest new online
store they sell all of the top organic
and healthy products at 25 to 50% off
ship straight to your door next to each
project at a product rather it shows a
retail price and then it shows the
thrive market price so you can see
exactly how much you're saving now I
know you're looking at me I don't look
exactly like the kind of guy who eats
healthy all of the time that's true but
sweet little Alisa my fiancee she does
she cooks healthy Sheila this is a
really great service so you get the best
quality product
thrive market has all the top premium
healthy organic products that you
usually get from the grocery store but
unlike your typical grocery and non-gmo
products that are marked up to crazy
prices thrive market sells the same
organic and non-gmo premium products at
wholesale prices so one of the other
reasons that I don't always buy the
healthiest foods is of course because I
don't receive a salary but now now
fortunately thanks to thrive market that
is much less of an issue so how do they
do it the way they do it is they cut out
all of the middlemen that goes directly
to you they work directly with brands
they pass all of the savings on to their
members they also give back which is
really nice so whoever whenever you sign
up for one of these memberships they'll
will give one to someone who is a
veteran or low income family or a
teacher so together they make healthy
living affordable to everyone if left to
my own devices I would just eat like
week-old sausage and swaddled in my own
filth in my apartment thankfully there
are like there's my fiancee sweet little
ELISA and people who try to help you to
live a healthier lifestyle that we can
all do that together it's a really
really great model it's much easier than
the grocery store to
as a millennial myself I never want to
leave a chair I would've used with my
chair I never leave my computer my phone
that's perfect I don't think I've been
to a grocery store in like a year
fortunately its rivals bring everything
to you it's also a curated catalogue so
sometime you go to the grocery store and
they have 350 different kinds of olive
oil and you think well I can't really
decide which the best olive oil is so
thrive market curates all of its
selections they'll have two or three and
you know you're getting the best they do
all of the homework for you and today
this is an extra Christmas present for
all of our listeners and viewers you get
sixty dollars of free organic groceries
plus free shipping plus a 30-day trial
membership that sounds too good to be
true but it's not and it's how I'm gonna
be eating well my fiance is in New York
so you get sixty dollars of free organic
groceries free shipping and a 30-day
trial membership there is absolutely no
reason not to do this right now
that is thrive market dot-com slash
Michael that's mi CH AE L thrive market
comm slash Michael keep in mind these
prices are already 25% to 50% below the
retail because they cut out the
middleman
now you're getting extra $60 plus
shipping plus the membership trial on
top of that I don't know how they can do
this but take advantage of it while it
lasts is a really really good deal and
so $60 off of free food make sure you do
a thrive market.com slash Michael okay I
was gonna do you see I have my little
Christmas tree tie on today this was
from Cynthia who does all of the
wonderful artwork around here it plays
music so I was gonna do this nice show
about Christmas but then then this
wonderful speech came out from about the
United Nations so Nikki Haley turns my
home warning around here she is ahead of
a vote by the UN General Assembly
condemning the United States for moving
our embassy in Israel to the capital of
Israel the United States is by far the
single largest contributor to the United
Nations and its agencies when a nation
is singled out for attack in this
organization that nation is disrespected
what's more that nation is asked to pay
for the privilege of being disrespected
the United States will remember this day
in which it was singled out for attack
in the General Assembly for the very act
of exercising our right as a sovereign
nation we will remember it when we are
called upon to once again make the
world's largest contribution to the
United Nations and we will remember when
so many countries come calling on us as
they so often do to pay even more and to
use our influence for their benefit be
still my beating heart oh my god I just
want to watch it like three more times
this is so beautiful this is the sort of
thing we've been waiting to see from the
United Nations for a long time she has
been wonderful in this role so she's
laying down the SmackDown President
Trump warned people to nevertheless
undeterred the United Nations voted 128
to 9 to condemn the United States the
only nations that voted against this
resolution are Guatemala Honduras Israel
Marshall Islands Micronesia Nauru Palau
Togo and the United States a bunch of
other islands rather a bunch of other
nations abstained Antigua Barbuda
Argentina Australia Bahamas Benin Bhutan
Bosnia Cameroon Canada Colombia Croatia
check dr Equatorial Guinea Fiji Haiti
Hungary Jamaica
Kiribati Latvia Lesotho Malawi Mexico
Panama Philippines Poland Romania Rwanda
Solomon Island South Sudan Trinidad and
Tobago Tuvalu Uganda and Van out to
Vanuatu
but where are our allies where are our
allies you might remember that you can't
even pronounce most of those names
because you don't hear the United Nation
or the United Kingdom
you don't hear France you don't hear
Italy a lot of our allies voted against
us 128 different nations including our
allies voted to condemn the United
States at the UN for exercising and
sovereign right to establish embassies
where it so pleases so we might cut
their foreign aid and listen to them
whine the Turkish Foreign Minister
nevelot Cavazos Lew said we were all
asked to vote no or face concept
winces some even threatened to cut
development aid some the United States
the people that give you development aid
this is bullying it is unethical to
think that the votes and dignity of
member states are for sale
is that right okay that's fine but you
can't stand on your box and preen and
moralize well you've got your handout
taking money good luck guys that's okay
you want to vote how you want you want
to bite the hand that feeds you you want
to condemn the greatest force for peace
and prosperity in the history of the
world the only reason that we've had
peace relative peace for a century or
three-quarters of a century fine
fine by me go ahead guys back-to-back
world war winners that that's absolutely
fine but we don't need to give you money
let's go over some numbers the United
States pays twenty eight point five
percent of the 7.3 billion dollar UN
peacekeeping budget we pay twenty two
percent of the core budget of 2.7
billion dollars since 1948 since it was
founded the United Nations has spent
almost 109 billion dollars on
peacekeeping missions now countries
speaking in support of this measure
today were North Korea Yemen Turkey
Venezuela Cuba Syria South Africa and
Iran not to be outdone Hamas also
praised the resolution you're known by
the friends you keep so why exactly do
we have it why do we have the UN we have
the worst people in the world standing
up and condemning us for this former UN
Ambassador John Bolton sums it up point
that I want to leave with you in this
very brief presentation is where I
started is there is no United Nations
there is an international community that
occasionally can be led by the only real
power left in the world and that's the
United States
when it suits our interest and when we
can get others to go along Secretariat
building in New York has 38 stories if
you lost 10 stories today it would make
a bit of difference this kind of
mindless creation of the United Nations
as something different than what it's in
the United States interest
do isn't gonna sell here or anywhere
else
the United States makes the UN work when
it wants it to work and that is exactly
the way it could be because the only
question the only question to the United
States is what's in our national
interest and if you don't like that I'm
sorry but that is the fact I love who so
much one of the greatest things the
president george w bush ever did was
make that man the ambassador to the
united nations III one time had lunch
with a former UN Ambassador and I said
is it possible for a Republican to be
the UN Ambassador you know is it
possible to be an ambassador to the
United Nations and still support the
United Nations and he said yes you have
to support the basic mission of the
United Nations unless your John Bolton
you can get out of it is really
beautiful and he sums it up exactly as
it is now during the Cold War the United
Nations stayed out of the peacekeeping
business why is that because you had the
brink of glow a global nuclear conflict
and all of these little peacekeeping
endeavors would have been proxy wars
between the United States and the Soviet
Union so let's just look since the 90s
after the Cold War humanitarian crises
in the Balkans Somalia and Cambodia led
the UN to dramatically increase its
peace operations funding and yet despite
all of the additional funding and
activity it utterly failed it failed
utterly it failed in Somalia it failed
in the Rwandan genocide it failed in
Bosnia according to the high-level
independent panel on UN peace operations
quote more than 98 percent of military
and police personnel deployed in UN
peacekeeping missions today have a
mandate to protect civilians as part of
integrated mission wide efforts the UN
has deployed peacekeeping missions on 70
occasions over the past 70 or so years
it has sort of succeeded in two of them
Sierra Leone in the early 2000s Burundi
later that decade it only even
intervened to protect civilians in 20%
of the cases for which it was authorized
to do so by the UN Security Council
that's its main mandate 98 percent
mandate only 20% of the time didn't even
try to come through at 2007 UN office of
internal oversight services report
showed that 40% of peacekeeping
contracts
analyzed contained significant
corruption schemes to the tune of 619
million dollars 40% of the ones that
just the ones that were analyzed the UN
mission in Sudan alone squandered tens
of millions of dollars in mismanagement
waste fraud and corruption
now we've recently discovered widespread
fraud by UN peacekeepers in Western
Sahara peacekeepers illegally reselling
food in Lebanon that's where our
investments are going that's where our
charity is going to enrich peacekeepers
selling of UN peacekeeping jobs in Haiti
and the Democratic Republic of the Congo
the most ironically named country in the
history of the world these are just the
corruption cases that happen to have
been exposed there are plenty of others
the UN is classically very secretive
with its own internal operations those
are just the ones we know about
in 1975 the UN adopted the resolution
Zionism is racism you'll notice a
running theme at the UN they're not a
big fan of the Jews you know now that in
the history of the world many people
have tried to kill the Jews this has not
changed over time they're God's chosen
people it's not terribly surprising that
this would happen it's the central
failure though of the United Nations
which is moral relativism the UN during
its founding period was much much better
than it is today because it was limited
to countries that had declared war
against the Axis powers in World War two
so yes it might have included Stalin it
wasn't all great wonderful Western
liberal democracies but it exclusively
kept people out who had been on the
wrong side of that war had been on the
side of evil clear evil the modern UN
bears no relationship to this whatsoever
in 2011 this is unbelievable in 2011 the
United Nations General Assembly held a
moment of silence to honor a deceased
leader of a country do you know who that
leader was marshal do you have any idea
yeah that would be Kim jong-il the
dictator of North Korea one of the worst
people ever deliv they held a moment of
silence to honor him it is we have to
end the United Nations we have to defund
it I see two options here either we can
admit the reality of this they admit the
reality that John Bolton is talking
about and say
there is no such thing as a United
Nations this is a ridiculous fiction the
United States is the global superpower
we're going to do what we want to do
we're perfectly happy to listen to other
people's ideas we're perfectly happy to
form coalition's but we're not going to
pretend that little nations or little
nations that aren't even really nations
there would be nations they get to tell
us what to do they have an equal seat at
the table is the United States we can
call it the American forum we're happy
to pay for the whole thing we're happy
to host it and these terrible terrible
people can come groveling to us and beg
our mercy and beg our forgiveness and
beg us to help them and we'd be
perfectly happy to assume that global
leadership and consider their proposals
that's one world or they can have their
United Nations that's perfectly fine
we'll pay the twenty thousand dollars a
year that many of those countries pay
virtually nothing will contribute very
little they don't get to come to our
soil right now the United Nations is
hosted in New York City it is ludicrous
it is one of the most ludicrous aspects
of American foreign policy that with
regard to the United Nations we invite
the worst people on earth to come to our
soil to come to our best city the best
city in the world and then stand on a
platform and criticizes and condemn us
horrible human rights abusers brutal
tyrants butchers themselves get to stand
on our soil in our city and condemn us
for what for nothing because we try to
stop them when they brutalize their own
people so that's fine if they want to
have a United Nations maybe we'll even
participate you don't get our money you
don't get to do it in our country host
it in your country see how that works
you pay for the security for it to work
in your country absolutely fine by me it
is a fiction there's a feeling I think
among people of the old liberal
consensus or on the Left who say well it
helps us to exert influence in the world
we can exert as much influence in the
world as we like we don't need to play
into any fictions the United Nations has
utterly failed when it's tried to
intervene in humanitarian conflicts it
has made matters worse it has made chaos
in the world worse because it's given
voices to terrible people who should
shut their mouths at the end of our guns
that were they should be totally
understand that they're our allies in
this world led by the United States
who will put them down UN peacekeepers
they don't protect the peace they don't
protect civilians get rid of it there
isn't any argument for it I'm glad that
we've it appears that the Trump
administration has trolled them doing it
into doing exactly what he's wanted to
do since the beginning which is defund
this ridiculous institution they should
knock down that building and turn it
into the new Trump Towers on the East
River I think it'd be very beautiful I'm
flying out to New York tonight
I'll start scoping out the land there's
a great cigar bar nearby maybe I'll buy
a room when it becomes Trump Tower
okay enough on the UN we're gonna have
such a nice show today about the
Nativity and the Incarnation but they
get you so riled up these awful awful
people and it's just really wonderful
that finally after eight years of Barack
Obama who bungled every aspect of
American leadership in the world we have
people with the moral clarity like nikki
Haley who's sitting at the UN and
incredibly too many Donald Trump who has
moral clarity on world leadership let's
get into the mailbag the first question
comes from John hey Michael aka
Hillary's third cousin two times removed
I noticed a common debate among liberals
is that the reason there is a cycle of
poverty in black communities is because
the schools are poorly funded what is
your take on this can we expect people
to rise out of poverty when their
education is lacking funding and where
can this funding come from when the
communities are struggling thank you
John
I've heard this before too a lot of
people talk about this we need to find
we shouldn't have any Wars we shouldn't
have any security operations we
shouldn't build a wall we need to fund
the schools because there are racial
disparities racial disparities in
success are caused by school funding the
trouble with this theory is that it
isn't true
so Columbia University's Linda
darling-hammond claimed this the
n-double a-c-p claims this the College
Board President Gaston Caperton declared
quote tests are not the problem the
problem we have is an unfair education
system in America an unequal education
system so two things here first
increasing school spending has rarely
led to better outcomes second according
to the US Department of Education
assumed funding disparities between
racial and ethnic groups do not exist
that's according to the Department of
Education ironically though
so the the trope the myth is that much
more money is spent on white students
than any other race of students
ironically the opposite is true more
money in the United States is spent on
minority students than white students
nationally and regionally this is
according to the US Department of
Education National Center for Education
Statistics so nationally a black
students get 105 percent of funding so
an additional 5% of funding than white
students Hispanic students get 1% more
funding Asian students get 7% more
funding when you break it down
regionally in the northeast black
students get per student 16% more
funding Hispanic students 17% more
funding Asian students 12% more funding
in the South even in the south that
awful terrible rural South backwards Jim
Crow black students get 5% more funding
Hispanic students get 3% more Asian
students get 9% more in the Midwest
black students get 13% more Hispanic
students get 6% more Asian students get
11% more and in the West black students
get 11 % more Hispanic students get 6%
more Asian students get 8% more it's a
total lie
to talk about discrepancies because it's
exactly the opposite of what the left
says it is now in perspective black
students receive over two thousand
dollars more than white student in per
pupil funding each and every year why
are there disparities in educational
attainment or in poverty you you'd have
to there are many many factors of this
some historical some cultural but I
would look at the culture there are some
immigrant groups succeed in the United
States some immigrant groups do not
succeed in the United States some native
groups succeed some non-native group
some native groups succeed at lower
rates I think culture is the answer
culture is what we worship it comes for
it comes from the same word as cult what
we're looking to cultures that emphasize
two-parent households and not having
children out of wedlock and getting
married and saving money and having
education and pursuing professional
careers will succeed at higher rates
what would the single greatest predictor
of financial success in the United
States is being born to a two family
home now when it comes to the black
community something like three-quarters
of black babies in the United States
are born out of wedlock this is a major
cultural issue it's only been happening
for the last 50 years or so so sit
before the Great Society before
Democrats and LBJ decided that they were
going to explode the welfare state to
help to ostensibly help black families
black murder rates were going down
poverty was going down everything was
going right for that community of
Americans since that time all of those
trends have reversed we have to look at
culture and we have to look at perverse
government incentives that have that
have ravaged the the black community if
you want to really be able to explain
and fix different levels of attainment
oK we've got many more questions to
change your life but if you're not on
daily wire.com you won't be able to see
them it's Christmas treat yourself we
are what were four days away from
Christmas now go to daily wire calm it
costs $10 a month or $100 for an annual
membership what do you get for that you
get me you get the Andrew Clavin show
you get the Ben Shapiro show you get no
ads on the website it's none of that
matters we are about to have a blizzard
folks this has been an incredible year
just just a quick little recap we've got
major tax reform Obamacare mandate
repealed Isis defeated militarily
consumer confidence at all time highs
markets at all-time highs we've got four
percent projected economic growth which
Obama's economists told us was
absolutely impossible
we have originalist justice on the
Supreme Court we have original lists I
think twenty eight originalist
appointed to federal courts massive
deregulation deregulation that we
haven't seen in decade upon decade
probably since Coolidge something like
zero net new regulations this year
compared to it an annual average of
13,000 we've got Pro energy policies
going into effect we're gonna be looking
at drilling in Anwar you are gonna be
covered in a blizzard
get your leftist tears tumblr before
those salty little snowflakes rain down
on you and crush you this is very
dangerous this time of year you could
get hypothermia or frostbite from all of
the or you'll just be dried out from all
the salt so go to Daley wire.com right
now we'll be right back
next question is from Jacob Jacob says
hi Michael I'm a veteran
thank you very service and I've dealt
with suicide and mental health issues
myself how do you think the suicide
problem in the veteran community can be
fixed because as of now on average 22
veterans commit suicide per day very
sorry to hear about that Jacob one thing
I hope is that you're getting a
treatment for mental health so that
you're seeing a psychiatrist who can
help you it's also good to see a priest
it's also good to see someone who can
help you on the spiritual side of that
but you should see a medical
professional as well and it's especially
good if you see a medical professional
who shares your spiritual views as well
that is a very effective way to be
treated for these tough issues now we
see the story a lot there is a national
epidemic of suicide among veterans those
numbers are a little misleading so I
hope that you don't feel like you're
being washed away in just a tidal wave
of suicides because the situation
actually isn't quite as bleak as that so
the vast majority of these suicides are
among older veterans national suicide
rate among military veterans is 38.4 per
100,000 and this is higher than average
but nationally just men in their 50s
alone commit suicide at around 30 30 per
100,000 so it is higher it's
significantly higher among veterans but
compared to 95% of military veterans are
men the majority of these suicides are
vast majority or older men so the
numbers actually are much more in line
with the general population than people
would think mostly because most of these
suicides are being committed by older
men so nationally also there's one
completed suicide for every 25 suicide
attempts the trouble is military
veterans on average are more likely to
have firearms and to know how to use
them so there they complete suicide much
more than the general population this is
all really tough stuff obviously
military service can take a major toll
and this culture takes a major toll
suicide numbers are up after years of
declining suus
members are increasing among the general
population there are with regard to
veterans obviously mental health access
is really important and the total
failure of the Veteran Affairs
administration is to blame for a lot of
this all of my veteran friends without
exception have great difficulty
accessing the VA this is awful
Democrats want to expand this to cover
all of our health care and they
shouldn't look at the failures of the VA
and the failure on veterans and let that
be a lesson to everybody when it comes
to nationalized or socialist health care
so right now one of the reason that the
suicide rate is increasing possibly is
that now veterans of the Vietnam War
veteran veterans are getting even older
and they're entering into this
particularly risky age bracket for
suicide one of the reasons that the
suicide rate nationally is going up
could be caused by decreasing
religiosity number of studies have found
that religious people church-going
people are significantly less suicidal
Catholicism in particular appears to
have a correlation with lower suicide
rates that this may have to do with its
stance on divorce being a happy marriage
or really any marriage is a good
predictor of not committing suicide
there are also obviously moral
foundations teleological visions to
religion that will play into this as
well an idea that there's a purpose
there's a reason for me to be here
suffering isn't the end of the world
most people and most of the history of
the world have suffered and that
suffering can be sanctifying and it can
be for a purpose and it can be and it
can even be good it can be refining
suffering itself has no moral value to
it
it's only your reaction to suffering
that has a moral value so if you react
to suffering with courage and dignity
and perseverance and transcendence and
you know kissing it up to God that's a
that's a wonderful reaction to suffering
and if you react to it with self-pity
and with self-destruction
that's a morally bad reaction to it the
most important thing here from a policy
level is to make sure that veterans and
the American people have easy access to
mental health services the cultural
vision is that we need to make sure
we don't can persist in a nihilistic
culture and from your personal
experience make sure you're getting the
help that you can there are a ton of
resources out there for you and many of
them are free make sure you do that and
thank you for your service and I hope
you get better from Benjamin hello
Michael
I love your show thank you I'm a
recently retired lobbyist from the
Kentucky legislature on Wednesday night
Rep Dan Johnson committed suicide
presumably in response to unproven
allegations that he molested a teenager
in quotes in reading the police report
information who did not press charges
because of lack of evidence beyond the
he-said she-said what is alleged to have
happened is that representative Johnson
had too much to drink and he ended up
fondling a 17 year old girl against her
will of course there are no distinctions
drawn here in our media between the
difference between a teenager can rage a
few days / 12 - a few days shy of 18 I
think one important thing that moral
thought leaders need to do more of is to
speak of the sins of calumny and
detraction how many among us could
withstand in the public sphere a
scrutiny and expose of our personal
lives whatever the facts of this case
it's my opinion that Dan's wife is right
this was a high-tech lynching of her
husband why do so many people think it
is morally licit to spread true
information about others to destroy
their character thank you Mike and
Louisville this is a really tough one I
I did run this story I talked about this
a little bit I think last week two weeks
ago this is really sad story all around
but especially in this climate where
we're comparing a guy who gets a little
drunk and a little handsy but no more
than that with a guy like Harvey
Weinstein who's a serial rapist a couple
thoughts on this one if you run for
office I've worked on a lot of political
campaigns if you run for office you have
to assume that people will do these
sorts of things to you you have to make
sure that you have the stability and a
thick enough skin to withstand the worst
sorts of lives or even worse the worst
sorts of truths that are being spread
about you on campaigns that I've worked
on there have been people on both sides
of the campaign our opponents and on our
campaigns whose job it is to find dirt
and oppo and ruin a guy's life so that
he loses the election now there's a rule
that I've always tried to to keep in my
mind on campaigns if we've
if we ever find anything truly truly
awful you I think you should always
bring it to the other campaign I don't
mean awful like it's gonna kill his
campaign or even his career I mean awful
like it's gonna ruin this guy's life in
his marriage you should bring it to the
other campaign first and say you've got
24 hours to get out of the race or we
are going to release this if they don't
comply it's all fair game
politics is a very very messy dirty
business unfortunately it often attracts
mentally unstable people of people who
don't have a terribly thick skin and it
can result in these awful things but you
got to be aware of that it's easy on
campaigns to get carried away and say oh
yeah we got this dirt we're gonna win
this race but politics isn't everything
and you're gonna have to answer what you
do someday so make sure even when you're
brawling you're bloody your tough in
politics which is every single campaign
make sure that you're not compromising
your moral soul make sure that you're
playing at least in a way where you
could look at yourself in the mirror I
was a really sad story all around and
probably it was a combination of
representative Johnson not having the
understanding of what politics how dirty
it can get how awful it's gonna be not
maybe having that really bone thick skin
and also a reach on the other side that
was just a really vicious vicious attack
and they're gonna have to answer for
that too
next question from Seamus hi Michael do
you think it's appropriate for
secularists atheists and other
non-christians to celebrate Christmas
absolutely absolutely I was talking to
Matt Walsh about this yesterday Matt I
think thinks if you don't belong to a
Benedictine monastery and say 20 novenas
a day
you shouldn't celebrate Christmas maybe
I'm exaggerating a little I don't think
that Andrew Clavin is a great example on
this if you read his book which is very
very good the great good thing a secular
Jew comes to faith in Christ if you read
his book he converted to Christianity
around age 50 and one of the seeds for
that conversion which was born out of
literature and born out of understanding
narrative in the world and coming to
Christ through that he was basically
converted by a Christmas cookie when he
was a little kid he loved Christmas
celebrations he loved going over
to a family friend's house and seeing
the decorations and participating in
that that could have a wonderful effect
Christmas is the the Incarnation Christ
comes he's conceived of the Holy Spirit
born of the Virgin Mary he becomes man
excuse me
the divine logos of the universe in that
moment one of the first stories we see
in the infancy narratives are these
three wise men and they come from the
east they come from the land of the
sunrise and they're not Jews they are
probably Zoroastrians Eastern priests
and the word magic and magician comes
from Magi and but they there's a talk in
the town there's talk in the air that
the king of the world will be born in
Judea and so they walk and they walk
through and they're they're led by the
star to Christ that is always important
in our world Christ comes into the world
so that all of the nations will come and
worship Him and and we don't have to
make people insist on people doing it on
our terms
Herod didn't say you have to become Jews
before you can go see Christ you know
and what he really said was tell me
where he is so I can go kill him and
they went they left by another way they
came to Christ by one way and those Magi
left by another way physically and
metaphysically so on the physical side
they didn't want to tell Herod where he
was and have to get killed on the
metaphysical side they changed their
minds and a lot of things can change
your mind a lot of things can bring you
to Christ that you wouldn't expect it's
not within your rational ability to
limit what can bring you to Christ so
absolutely everybody should break at the
Santa Claus and the reindeers and the
snowmen and frosty and Rudolph whatever
just bring them along Christmas is a
gateway drug to two metaphysical truth
and the divine logos of the universe and
it's very fun and enjoyable so do it
from coal hello Michael
I very much enjoy the show and like the
beautiful women you often bring on for
the panel of deplorable so you're
telling me buddy keep up the great work
thank you my question big shock regards
the Catholic faith I never get any of
those that's so strange
okay I must admit I've been drawn to it
recently but I can't help but feel the
Pope
is misrepresenting the faith I think you
mean to say he seems more interested in
spitting out left-wing propaganda rather
than representing Christ is a Catholic
are you able to think critically of your
leaders or does this get you in trouble
with the church I'd hate to put you on
the spot light with your faith but the
current Pope for some reason has made me
question becoming a Catholic could you
please help me thanks you should become
a Catholic anyway don't don't worry
about that
Oh over time a lot of misconceptions
have come out of the Catholic Church so
one is that the Pope is totally
infallible and whatever he says goes and
if he says the sky is purple then the
sky's not gonna be blue that's gonna be
purple whatever if he says two plus two
equals seven then that becomes the truth
but that isn't the case the Pope is
infallible in a very limited number of
things we've had good Pope's and we've
had bad popes the church lady is
encouraged to think critically and to
think for themselves Dante the Divine
poet one of the most important figures
who offers one of the most beautiful
visions of eternity Dante put a couple
Pope's in Hell so he you put them there
himself that that isn't the worst thing
in the world an important aspect here is
to think about the difference between
the mainstream media portraying Pope
Francis and Pope Francis himself so I'm
not willing to compare Pope Francis with
the various pontiff's who have gone to
hell because what we read in the media
is so often not true they don't
understand anything about the Catholic
faith so they don't understand anything
about what he is saying people would
have you the mainstream media would have
you think that Pope Francis is going to
get gay-married next week and and paint
the Vatican and rainbows but Pope
Francis said when he was Cardinal Norton
Tina he said do not be mistaken
same-sex marriage is not a mere
political lobby it's a machination of
the father of lies that seeks to deceive
and confuse the children of God that
does not jibe with the image that we are
presented with by Newsweek of Pope
Francis
but that said Pope Francis has said some
things that are a little strange that we
might not all agree with recently a
group of conservative Catholics and
theologians presented him
with a filial correction for heresy they
formally accused him of heresy in a very
nice and polite and orderly way if you
find yourself being drawn to the church
universal as I have been in my life I
would keep pursuing that and I wouldn't
let one cleric that you don't
particularly care for it dissuade you
it's been around for 2,000 years and
there have been some clerics that you
won't agree with and some orders that
you won't agree with you know very often
conservatives make fun of the Jesuits
because they lean left and they get
their little clever you know so someone
was asked the difference between the
Dominican Order and the Jesuit Order and
they said well what are the similarities
I said well you know both were formed in
Spain one by Saint Dominic one by
Ignatius of Loyola and both were founded
to combat heresy so the Dominicans were
formed to combat the Alba Jenson's and
the Jesuits were formed to fight the
Protestants so guy says well what's the
difference between the Dominicans and
the Jesuits and the answer is have you
met any Alba Jenson's lately we mock
Jesuits all the time that's okay you can
feel free to veer into very conservative
aspects of the church but come on over
if you're interested the water is great
Bal and I hope that answers your
question from Christian dear Knowles can
you prove the Gospels really are
authentic and why don't the why the Jews
don't see it that way well I don't I
don't know that the Jews writ large
questioned the historicity of the
Gospels certainly they don't believe in
the divinity of Christ by definition I
suppose but the scholarly consensus is
clear the scholarly consensus right now
is that the Gospel according to mark was
written within 40 years of Jesus's death
Matthew within 40 to 70 years
Luke within 30 to 60 years John within
50 to 65 years that's on the outside end
so think about it this way would you
trust a biography today that was written
about Andy Kaufman Andy Kaufman was
about 35 years old when he died he died
about 33 years ago would you trust that
or would you say no that's absolutely
ridiculous how could they know about
Andy Kaufman oh there are people alive
who knew him and we have movies and we
have books about him
historians all certainly also agree that
about jesus' baptism by John the Baptist
and his death by Pontius Pilate they all
agree that those occurred they might
disagree about some of the miracles
Flavius Josephus the Roman historian
writes about Christ and his followers
Tacitus the Talmud writes about Christ
it I think it's very fashionable now to
question the historicity of Christ or to
question the Gospel accounts we know
more about him than we know about
virtually anyone else of that era we
know we and we can rely on more than
that so when you engage with the text on
that level but you should just read it
you should read these accounts and
encounter this person and then you'll
have to grapple with Christ Himself
you'll have to grapple with the person
of Christ and CS Lewis writes about this
when you meet him you have three options
he's either a liar he's either just
deceiving people going around deceiving
everybody or he's a lunatic and he's
seen he's just a total crazy person or
he's the Lord or he's the person he says
he is and I'll tell you when you read
those books he sure doesn't come off as
a liar he has no incentive to be a liar
and he doesn't get great rewards for his
lies that's certainly true infinite
torture on a cross and he doesn't seem a
lunatic he does not sound like a lunatic
when you read him and you read his
piercing words and his and his piercing
actions so it's hard not to conclude the
latter but your mileage might vary you
should read it yourself from Stephanie
hi Michael can you give me a reference
for the Pascal quote you mentioned on
Tuesday aside from it being somewhere in
the ponse or in the thoughts of best gal
it was something to the effect of being
a gentleman instead of being known for
what one writes yes Pascal is one of the
incredible genius of modernity most
people know him by Pascal's wager so his
wager is you should believe in
Christianity because if you're wrong you
lose nothing and or if you're wrong
you'll burn in hell for eternity
and if you're right you lose you know
you gain all of infinity so
unfortunately he died at age 39 he
invented the calculator who's a
mathematician who's a physicist child
prodigy and a Catholic theologian he
wrote in his thoughts which are just a
notes he was putting together for a book
that he didn't live long enough to write
he said man is full of wants he only
loves those who
satisfy them all he's a good
mathematician say they but I have
nothing to do with mathematics he would
take me for a proposition he is a good
soldier he will take me for a besieged
place what I wanted is a gentleman who
can adapt himself to all my wants in a
general way we should not be able to say
either that he is a mathematician a
preacher or an orator but that he's a
gentleman this quality of universality
is the only one that pleases me and it's
especially important in our day where
everyone specializes even professors
nobody is a professor of literature
anymore nobody's a professor of history
anymore
they're professors of the Gender Studies
read through Derrida from 1967 to 1967
and a half the specialization is so so
intense that you don't have people who
have more qualities who are known by
more than just their job who are known
by more than just where they live or
their friends the quality of being a
gentleman is really something that we
could look back to and I think it would
balance out a lot of the anxiety that
people feel today from Betsy hi Michael
I've often heard you discuss your own
path from being basically atheist when
you were confirmed to finding God again
through evangelists and then finally
landing back firmly in Catholicism my
nephew is preparing to be confirmed
Catholic this spring and my sister his
mom has told me that he's an atheist and
she has to drag him to church he is an
extremely intelligent kid and
unfortunately his high intelligence
translates to a know-it-all cynicism
he's 14 yeah I hear about that can you
offer any tips for how to make him turn
back toward God and in particular our
Catholic faith should he speak to
someone who's going through a similar
journey a priest I worry about her
slightly out of touch not great with
kids Monsignor turning him further from
the faith I think of having him read CS
Lewis he's an avid reader but you know I
wonder if one can force a kid to read
something that he doesn't want to read
any help would be appreciated okay yes I
will take this on I experienced this
myself
it's very very fitting that you're
highly intelligent 14 year-old nephew is
an atheist atheism is tailor-made for
people who have the
wisdom and the ignorance of and the
arrogance of smart 14-year olds that is
the key demographic it makes perfect
sense when you're a smart 14 year old
you question everything you're taught
but you're not unfortunately or 14 so
you're not smart enough you don't have
any experience or any maturity or any
deepened understanding of the world or
even any education so you can't get past
that hurdle it bill Whittle talks about
that island 120 he said sort of the
dumbest people are conservatives and the
middle tier are liberals and then the
smart people are conservatives again and
that kind of middle tier is the New York
Times editorial board this exactly
happened to me I was a smarter than
average 13 14 year old so when I was
about to be confirmed I was an atheist I
said I was an atheist and my mother said
Michael just do it go through the
confirmation I think you're going
through a phase you will regret it if
you don't go through the with this later
on so I said okay and she was right
smarter than average 14-year old I read
all of those atheists Christopher
Hitchens and short Richard Dawkins and
Daniel Dennett and all of them Sam
Harris later when I was when I was 17
years old a couple days before Christmas
excuse me I get a little choked up with
this my mother died very unexpectedly
and that is an experience that matures
somebody and it's a very humbling
experience the experience of death close
up especially if you're young or
whatever the experience of the traumas
that we all face in our lives
deepen your understanding of the world
and they humble you and you realize oh
maybe I don't have all the answers maybe
I don't have control over everything in
the world during Advent the church
spends four Sunday's analyzing for
mysteries of life death judgment heaven
and hell these are mysteries that we
don't think about all of the time we
don't think about them every day or
every year even every 10 years but they
do confront us eventually and when we
can when we grapple with these things we
can be led up through into some maturity
you need that humility first which 14
year olds are constitutionally incapable
of then you need some education and as I
was educated I came to meet people who
were smarter than me who
made very good arguments for
Christianity modern apologists ancient
apologists the arguments for God are
much better than the arguments against
God I haven't really heard any coherent
arguments against God once you reach
that point and you've got some humility
and some maturity and some education
just a just even a little bit of any of
those can you reach that point again I
think and then after that I believe that
Christianity was true and only after
that did I have any real what would be
called religious sense a recognition or
numinous recognition that's probably not
the answer you want the answer you want
is probably not wait ten years wait for
the kid to experience some of the more
difficult parts of life and get a little
learning in his head but I wouldn't push
him
do not push him you're just gonna push
him further into his 14 year old atheist
delusions don't drag him to church I
didn't go to church for 10 years
probably you don't have to do that be a
little patient there's a time for every
purpose under heaven
just try to guide him a little bit in to
make sure he doesn't go off the wrong
path he gets a little humility he gets a
little maturity and and he will come
back especially if he's a smart kid
all right that's like that's a good
Christmas message to end on Merry
Christmas everybody
Happy New Year I will see you in 2018
thank you very much I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Doyle show
[Music]
the Michael Knoll show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017